[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous sens
public et au Salon International de
l'Agriculture ici sur le stand de la
coopération agricole vous le savez
depuis samedi sont toutes les émissions
de Public Sénat qui se délocalise ici
dans le pavillon 4 du salon Parc des
Expositions de la Porte de Versailles à
Paris un salon 2023 où les questions de
souveraineté alimentaire sont majeurs
d'autant plus crucial évidemment avec
les conséquences de la guerre en Ukraine
comment nourrir 67 millions de Français
alors que nos agriculteurs ne sont plus
que 5003 fois moins que dans les années
70 ce sera le thème de notre second
débat tout à l'heure mais d'abord on
pose les enjeux de ce salon en pleine
actualité sécheresse interdiction des
néonicotinoïdes rémunération des
exploitants en jeu que nous détaille
tout de suite Flora sauvage
souveraineté alimentaire pesticides
adaptation au changement climatique
parmi tous ces défis c’est la sécheresse
qui est au cœur de toutes les
préoccupations au salon de l'agriculture
[Musique]
crève alors que la France n'a pas connu
d'épisodes de pluie depuis le début de
l'année du jamais vu en hiver Emmanuel
Macron en visite au salon samedi a
appelé un plan d'économie de l'eau sur
le modèle du plan de sobriété
énergétique sur la sécheresse on doit
mieux utiliser nos eaux avoir moins de
fuite préserver justement les choses on
doit mettre en place ces structures
partout sur le territoire pour permettre
ces rétentions colinaires permettre aux
agriculteurs de fonctionner et la nation
a besoin de faire sur l'eau comme on l'a
fait sur l'énergie une forme de plans de
sobriété c'est à dire qu'on doit tous
nous citoyens industriels collectivités
locales et agriculteurs faire attention
à cette ressource qui deviendrace après
un été pauvre un précipitation la France
pourrait de nouveau connaître des
restrictions d'eau dès le mois de mars
pour les agriculteurs cette sobriété
nécessite de s'adapter de toute urgence
il y a la sobriété d'une part c'est à
dire que on doit être sur tous nos
usages y compris l'usage agricole encore
plus pointus encore plus précis avant
encore plus accès à la technologie qui
nous permet des économies et un usage
très pertinent de chaque goutte d'eau et
il y a aussi la partie qui l'a annoncé
qui concerne le stockage c'est à dire
que il faut un moment savoir gérer
l'abondance quand il y a de l'abondance
pour pouvoir stocker l'eau de pluie qui
tombe et pouvoir la relarguer en été
l'été s'annonce compliqué pour les
agriculteurs développer le recyclage des
eaux usées reste la piste privilégiée
par l'exécutif un décret est attendu
pour la fin mars
pour débattre notamment de cette
actualité de ces enjeux de sécheresse et
d'utilisation de l'eau j'accueille
Marion Guillou bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes présidente du je vous propose de
prendre le micro du conseil
d'administration d'agrinium l'Institut
agronomique vétérinaire et forestier de
France ancienne présidente de l'Institut
national de recherche pour l'agriculture
l'alimentation et l'environnement et
vous êtes membre du Haut Conseil pour le
climat j'accueil François pursègue
bonsoir bienvenue professeur de
sociologie à l'École nationale
supérieure agronomique de Toulouse et
vous publiez ce livre auteur co-auteur
avec Bertrand Hervieux une agriculture
sans agriculteur aux éditions des
Presses de Sciences Po Henri biespéré
bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi
vous êtes agriculteur dans les
Pyrénées-Atlantiques et vice-président
de la FNSEA et Mathieu croissanto
éditoris politiques est à mes côtés
bienvenue sur sur ce stand et et dans le
salon de l'agriculture Mathieu Marion
Guillou je commence avec vous quand on
discute avec des agricultrices des
agriculteurs dans les allées du salon
moi j'ai eu l'impression qui sont
confrontés à une sorte d'équation
impossible à résoudre il y a les défis
environnementaux on va en parler les
pesticides on va en parler nourrir des
dizaines de millions de de français avec
des ressources en eau on vient de le
voir dans le sujet qui sont de plus en
plus rares ou en tout cas sur lesquels
il peut y avoir même des conflits comme
on l'a vu l'été dernier le tout dans un
contexte général d'inflation de
l'énergie et des matières et des
matières premières est-ce que à vous
aussi elle vous semble parfois
impossible à résoudre cette équation
elle n'est pas possible mais elle est
difficile à résoudre c'est vrai mais
vous pouvez aussi regarder les signaux
plus positifs qu'on a eu récemment le
revenu la production agricole française
a recommencé à augmenter en valeur le
revenu des agriculteurs à recommencer à
augmenter donc oui la période est
difficile je dirais rare qu'on ait eu à
la suite la crise du covid la l'invasion
de l'Ukraine par la Russie plus un
contexte global de changement climatique
qui va rester là qui est là pour rester
mais si on veut regarder le côté positif
pendant le covid on n'a pas eu faim on a
été je veux dire on a trouvé au début il
y a eu quelques tensions sur farine 9
mais elle est mais c'est passé c'était
question de sachet ou de choses comme ça
mais l'agriculture a fourni ensuite
pendant le conflit avec l'Ukraine on a
craint une disons une famine mondiale
terrible et de fait sans doute grâce à
des bonnes récoltes dans certains pays
et à l'accord sur la circulation des
bateaux avec la Turquie éloignée de fait
on a passé cette crise alors là on se
retrouve devant des sécheresses
exceptionnelles un sécheresse de l'été
2002 vraiment 2022 vraiment exceptionnel
avec des baisses de production de forage
des baisses de production de culture
significatives et ce mois de février et
également historique mais là il faut on
peut encore attendre quand même la fin
d'hiver oui nous sommes en condition
climatiques très différentes d'avant et
il faut transformer les systèmes en
tenant compte de ces nouvelles
conditions climatiques François Purcell
si on parle de des vocations le fait
d'avoir de tels défis à résoudre est-ce
que ça freine l'évocation ou au compte
au contraire dans une nouvelle
génération et désagréteurs qui se disent
des jeunes agriculteurs agricultrices
ils disent bah il y a un super défi à
relever je le pense puisque ces métiers
de l'agriculture sont des métiers de
sens ces sens sont différents on a de
nouvelles générations qui se projettent
différemment dans les produits les
marchés agricoles dans ces exploitations
qui va falloir par contre peut-être
restructuré pour faire en sorte que
c'est nouvelle générations qui quelles
soient c'est-à-dire ces générations
d'enfants d'agriculteurs qui souhaitent
changer le système d'exploitation
famille puisse justement s'installer et
peut-être pas s'installer mais du moins
s'insérer différemment dans les métiers
de l'agriculture
Henri bienfait cette sécheresse
d'ailleurs à titre personnel dans votre
exploitation comment vous la ressentez
et puis peut-être évidemment plus plus
généralement
à titre personnel j'ai une chance
extraordinaire c'est que mes parents
dans les années 70 ont eu la possibilité
de faire des retenues colinéaires donc
en amont d'une rizière qui coule au
plein milieu de mon exploitation il y a
300 mm3 stockés pendant l'hiver quand il
pleut et qui sont lâchés dans leur
ruisseau et on donc ce qui permet de
d'entretenir les tirages du ruisseau et
on pompe dans le ruisseau pour arroser
nos cultures donc la sécheresse l'an
dernier a été n'a pas eu beaucoup
d'impact sur mon exploitation mais c'est
vraiment je fais partie des 7 8%
d'agriculteurs qui sont dans cette
situation là et malheureusement pour les
autres pour des voisins sur des villages
voisins la situation a été extrêmement
compliquée avec des cultures qui ont été
à peine 10% de leur rendement habituel
et ça veut dire que
l'enchaînement vous dont nous parlez
Mario Guy ou de la sécheresse de cet été
et de ce mois de février hors norme
est-ce que potentiellement il crée on
parle souvent de conflit de des
situations conflictuelles à venir alors
on est au 27 février et trop tôt
il faudrait qu'il pleuve vraiment d'ici
entre aujourd'hui et le mois d'avril
qu'il tombe vraiment des énormes
quantités d'eau parce que les réserves
dont je vous parlais ne sont pas tout à
fait pleines pour aborder sereinement la
campagne à venir donc le problème
effectivement pourrait s'accentuer si on
arrive pas et c'est là qu'effectivement
voilà il faut aussi agir sur
l'utilisation parti mondiale de l'os qui
a été abordé dans votre sujet
c'est-à-dire que ça ne nous empêche pas
de la gérer avec parcimonie parce que là
on va arriver à des situations
compliquées oui évidemment c'est ce que
vous nous disiez cette ce changement
climatique il est là pour durer et donc
il faut voilà inventer une agriculture
qui a prouvé sa résilience c'est ce que
vous nous décriviez et depuis plusieurs
mois avoir plusieurs années mais qui va
peut-être devoir l'être encore plus
Marion Guillou lors de sa visite samedi
le président de la de la République
parler des eaux usées on l'a vu dans le
dans le sujet de Flora sauvage est-ce
qu'on doit on parle aussi d'eau grise je
crois est-ce qu'on doit s'inspirer de ce
que font nos voisins du sud de l'Europe
et peut-être qu'on peut rappeler même si
ici beaucoup de gens le savent et pour
noter les spectateurs de quoi il s'agit
il s'agit des eaux qui partent de vos
lavabos enfin tous ce qui est récolté
qui est traitée et le sujet c'est
qu'actuellement en France on en
réutilise à peu près pas très très peu
alors que quand vous regardez en Espagne
on en utilise très très
significativement bien sûr quand vous
regardez en Israël c'est encore plus
donc la question qui se pose c'est en
Espagne pourquoi tout simplement parce
qu'ils ont encore plus besoin d'eau que
chez nous et donc qui ne ils ne gaspille
pas cette eau retraité donc le sujet
c'est un sujet sanitaire c'est être sûr
de la qualité de ces eaux traités mais
sous réserve de d'un certain nombre
d'assurance sur la qualité sanitaire on
voit pas du tout pourquoi on utiliserait
pas ces eaux
usées traitées pour la rosace des
jardins pour le nettoyage des villes il
y a un certain nombre d'utilisation où
on n'a pas forcément besoin d'eau
potabiliser ce qu'aujourd'hui
c'est tabou parce qu'on en avait pas
besoin je veux dire c'est toujours
pareil quand vous êtes en situation
l'eau n'était pas rare je veux dire il
tombe sur la France une quantité d'eau
énorme on utilise qu'une petite fraction
de l'eau en France si on a un problème
d'eau c'est à certains endroits et à
certaines périodes mais c'est là pour
revenir c'est-à-dire les sécheresses
qu'on a connu l'été dernier ou qu'on ne
qu'on vit conjoncturellement c'est pas
encore cet hiver c'est là pour revenir
et donc maintenant il faut avoir une
politique globale de l'eau beaucoup plus
par simonieuse que celle que nous avions
auparavant on était belle idée Dieu en
quelque sorte en matière de dos et c'est
pour ça qu'on n'a pas eu besoin de
s'inspirer des pays du Sud
oui oui on a manqué un peu de
d'anticipation est-ce qu'on peut on
avait l'habitude de dire qu'en France on
avait un climat quand même qui
accompagnait bien l'agriculture c'est
pour ça qu'elle a été florissante donc
tant qu'on n'avait pas ses événements
importants liés au changement climatique
on était dans un pays l'année l'an
dernier on parle de sécheresse à cela
n'est précédente chez moi il est tombé
un orage au 14 juillet et un autre vers
le 10 12 août ça a suffi pour conduire
les cultures sans pratiquement irriguer
du tout sans toucher aux retenu d'eau
donc on était dans un pays qui était
plutôt avec un climat et de l'eau qui
accompagnait bien les cultures parce que
vous avez effectivement vous avez
expliqué un système de de stockage en
quelque sorte de globalement sur notre
hexagone on est quand même on a un
climat qui plutôt accompagné bien et là
on a une succession d'année du gel de la
grêle et une sécheresse qui était qui a
compliqué particulièrement la situation
je pose cette question François Purcel
parce que
les agriculteurs ils se retrouvent
parfois entre entre le marteau et
l'enclume quoi on l'a vu l'été dernier
montrait du doigt par certains militants
écologistes accusés de stocker l'eau à
leur seul usage alors que c'est quand
même pour produire des aliments que nous
on va consommer après faut jamais
l'oublier comment c'est vécu justement
alors il y a un changement il y a une
mutation de des agriculteurs français
depuis plusieurs années le fait d'être
parfois montré du doigt c'est ça freine
l'évocation comment qu'est-ce que ça
forcément mais il est vrai que les
Français ont un regard différent sur
l'agriculture qui ne l'ont sur les
agriculteurs je pense pas qu'il y ait un
désamour des agriculteurs c'est vrai
qu'il y a une remise en question de
certaines pratiques mais attention je
pense que tous les agriculteurs ne
vivent pas ces situations de la même
manière c'est très variable d'une
filière à l'autre je pense pas que ça
soit un facteur de non attractivité mais
il est vrai que les agriculteurs sont
entrés en minorité dans une société et
toutes les minorités en fait finalement
ce caractérise par des controverses et
controverses socio-techniques quelle est
la profession qui n'est pas contro
aujourd'hui les journalistes sont
controversés
que les agriculteurs je vous l'accorde
finalement les agriculteurs découvrent
un peu sur le tard ce que sont ce qu'est
être une minorité c'est-à-dire être
bousculé dans ses pratiques
professionnelles mais ça ouvre de belles
perspectives pour le changement alors
cette cette sécheresse qui se qui
s'enchaînent je reste quand même sur sur
cette thématique vous propose un premier
témoignage dans cette émission celui de
Christian d'agneau qui est agriculteur
il est aussi président de la Chambre
d'Agriculture de la Charente il
témoignait cet été déjà sur la situation
écoutée il y a eu l'effort de chaleur
mais c'est surtout le manque de pluie
qui qui pénal les cultures puisque des
fortes chaleurs on a eu d'autres on en a
eu d'autres fois mais là c'est quand
est-ce cumule avec un manque de pluie
c'est catastrophique je suis à des
parcelles comme ici où on est si on a
des épisodes de sécheresse qui se
répètent comme cette année c'est bien
depuis la peine de mettre en culture
c'est c'est même plus la peine de mettre
en culture c'est cette phrase que je
retiens est-ce que ça arrive souvent ça
des recruteurs qui renoncent d'une
certaine façon pour les stars non
d'accord et c'est vrai qu'on a rarement
eu quand même plusieurs années
consécutives avec toutes ces difficultés
là mais l'agriculteur a du mal quand
même à renoncer c'est à dire qu'on va
chercher comme ça a été dit un peu tout
à l'heure de regarder changer peut-être
les SPS chargés changer les variétés
changer le mode de culture mais trouver
toujours des solutions pour continuer à
cultiver nos sols l'agriculteur dans son
âme a quand même envie d'apporter cette
nourriture dont on a besoin des
consommateurs français et donc il va
essayer de trouver quelques solutions
mais oui donc ce que j'entends c'est que
ça suppose de
réinventer un nouveau modèle est-ce que
vous allez jusque là
c'est pas forcément un nouveau modèle
c'est de faire évoluer effectivement un
modèle qui
a été jusqu'aujourd'hui à accompagner
l'agriculture et trouver peut-être une
variété afin de tout à l'heure ça a été
un peu évoqué la couverture des sols en
hiver qui était pas très pratique on
sait que ça permet quand même de mieux
retenir l'eau qui tombe et de la faire
pénétrer dans le sol plutôt que de
l'avoir ruisselé donc il ne faut évacuer
aucune des techniques qui permettent de
mieux retenir l'eau de d'améliorer la
qualité des sols on va changer les
périodes de semis on sait qu’encement
plutôt on va avoir des cultures qui vont
être plus en avance et qui vont éviter
les mois de juillet août ou en général
il fait beaucoup plus sec et donc comme
ça on va arriver à accompagner le la
conduite du exploitation en tenant
compte justement de ces logements
climatiques restera à vérifier comment
ça c'est ça le temps là c'est vrai qu'on
est particulièrement effaré parce qu'on
a eu trois années consécutives avec des
climats complètement différents et qui
ont touché des entière c'est pas des
micro-régieux c'était des dizaines de
départements qui étaient touchés en même
temps donc ça on est un peu dans les
spectative maintenant il faut rebondir
et se dire bon comment on fait et on a
besoin bien sûr de la science des
chercheurs de toutes les technologies
qui peuvent venir nous accompagner
Marion Guilloux je rappelle vous êtes
membre du Haut Conseil pour le climat
est-ce qu'on sait aujourd'hui dire
qu'elle est la part du réchauffement
climatique par exemple dans ce mois de
février qu'on vient qu'on vient de vivre
ou est-ce que c'est trop tôt alors pour
le mois de février c'est trop tôt un
affectation au changement climatique
n'est pas encore certaine en revanche la
sécheresse de l'été dernier et on sait
que les sécheresses seront beaucoup plus
récurrentes quand on regarde les
fréquences on a déjà observé dans les 20
dernières années elles étaient beaucoup
plus fréquentes que les vins tannés
précédentes donc on a un certain nombre
de choses
déjà observé et dont on peut être
certains que statistiquement elles
existeront beaucoup plus de vagues de
chaleur des extrêmes y compris des
pluies beaucoup plus abondantes
qu'auparavant par moment parce qu'on va
être dans de la sécheresse mais on va
aussi être dans des inondations de la
beaucoup plus de fréquences de
sécheresse donc tout ça est quand même
largement prévu statistiquement je ne
peux pas vous dire quelle année ou quel
mois précisément mais on sait que
statistiquement ça reviendra beaucoup
plus souvent je vais vous poser une
question basique mais si ça continue
comme ça est-ce que la nature de nos
productions va changer ou va devoir
changer on va devoir produire autre
chose en France de ce qu'on produit
jusqu'à maintenant oui
enfin ça change pas du jour au lendemain
ça a commencé de plus en plus de sorgho
par exemple
quand vous voyez maintenant les des vins
à 15 degrés alors qu'auparavant mais il
y a déjà longtemps mais quand j'étais
jeune il fallait parfois chaptaliser
parce qu'il y avait pas assez de sucre
dans le raisin je veux dire vous vous
rendez compte qu'on est passé les
situations complètement changé et on dit
déjà que la migration soit en altitude
soit vers le nord est une manière de
s'adapter au réchauffement donc oui on
va changer en géographie c'est-à-dire
deux zones géographiques d'implantation
des cultures et dans un endroit donné on
va vraisemblablement changer disons pour
le moindre de variétés pour avoir des
variétés mieux adaptées semi précoce
enfin donc des variétés par exemple et
puis on risque de changer aussi
d'espèces c'est d'avoir des espèces
comme le sorgho qui sont plus adaptés à
la sécheresse donc oui le paysage
agricole et la manière de les pratiques
agricoles vont devoir s'adapter au
changement climatique François puret ça
a commencé avec complètement cette
mutation des agriculteurs n'ont pas
attendu non plus ces ruptures
environnementales pour faire évoluer
leur pratique oui mais il y a toujours
un c'est long mieux placé que moi pour
le dire
ça prend du temps d'où la nécessité de
doter les agriculteurs et leurs familles
d'outils pour prendre en charge plus
rapidement peut-être ces transitions
parce que finalement les formes
d'organisation de la production
aujourd'hui sont pas toujours adaptés
assez défi à relever alors est-ce qu'on
peut être précis quel type d'outils les
outils de mutualisation un accès à de
nouvelles technologies un accès à une
capacité à mettre sur le marché
autrement à développer de nouveaux
marchés nouveaux circuits de
commercialisation alors toujours à
propos de la sécheresse maintenant
parler de nos forêts et rejoindre pour
ça Quentin Calmet qui est dans les dans
les allées du salon pour Public Sénat
voilà il se balade il va à la rencontre
des exposants des exploitants des
exploitants alors là on le retrouve avec
Brigitte musk qui est responsable du
Conservatoire générique des arbres
forestiers Quentin
oui voilà je suis avec Brigitte much
bonjour Brigitte vous êtes chargé de
recherche et développement à l'ONF sur
les questions du réchauffement
climatique avec le territoire français
les forêts en France qui sont touchés
par la sécheresse pas forcément comme on
se l'imaginerait que dans le sud de la
France ou dans le sud de la France et
oui on aurait
emails
de sécheresse elle se distribuent le
long de la vallée de la Garonne elle
remonte dans la vallée de la Loire où
nous avons nous chaîné mythiques troncé
par exemple et puis elle touche tout le
nord tout le nord de la France le massif
jurassien les Vosges et les hauts de
France la situation telle que vous
l'observez en ce moment elle est
inquiétante vous le dites oui elle est
inquiétante parce que c'est une
accumulation d'année de sécheresse
l'année dernière a été une année très
marquante pour les forestiers on a eu
que 2021 finalement depuis 2018 avec des
années de sécheresse à répétition donc
on accumule et les arbres marquent ce
temps de sécheresse dans leur bois et
ont de moins en moins de réserves pour
faire face aux futurs sécheresses alors
on pense bien sûr aux incendies mais il
y a pas forcément que ce risque là pour
la forêt et aussi un risque pour son
développement non alors il y a un risque
qui est multiple pour la forêt en effet
les incendies qui ont fortement marqué
en 2021 mais dans ces 2022 qui ont
surtout marqué en 2022 mais aussi
d'autres d'autres problèmes les arbres
lorsqu'ils ont pu assez d'eau arrêtent
de respirer donc arrête de grandir et
c'est vraiment un gros problème pour les
forestiers voire perdre l'oeufs et donc
vous votre métier c'est de chercher des
solutions et vous le dites ça va être
aussi une recherche génétique et aussi
une recherche de variétés d'arbres alors
dans
les ce que l'on veut mettre en place et
bien c'est de rechercher différentes
espèces à avoir des forêts beaucoup plus
diversifiées avec
des essences voilà un mélange avec par
exemple du chêne du boulot du pain et
puis d'autres espèces qui sont encore
présentes en forêt comme comme le hêtre
qui est juste là et vous le dites la
génétique la joie un rôle et la
génétique elle va jouer un rôle non
seulement sélectionnant des espèces qui
peuvent être plus adaptés aux nouvelles
conditions climatiques mais aussi ce que
l'on appelle des provenances c'est à
dire des origines géographiques qui ont
depuis des générations connues des
sécheresses à répétition et qui se sont
habitués et ça a été intégré dans leur
descendants un dernier mot il nous reste
quelques secondes pour évoquer l'été
prochain à très court terme est-ce qu'on
risque d'avoir d'importants incendies
cet été on peut absolument pas écarter
les incendies
à la fois dans les zones qui ont
l'habitude hélas d'avoir des incendies
je pense Méditerranée je pense sud-ouest
mais aussi dans d'autres zones comme on
l'a vu cet été dans le Jura par exemple
et même en Bretagne dans les dans les
Monts d'Arrée donc plus personne est à
l'abri des incendies de forêt merci
Brigitte muche pour toutes ces
explications et on retrouve tout ce
stand toutes ces explications sur le
stand de l' ONF c'est dans le hall 4
le hall 4 où nous sommes toujours ici
pour ce sens public en direct du Salon
de l'Agriculture
Marion Guillou un mot peut-être puis
ensuite on va on va changer de chapitre
dans ce dans ce premier débat mais
là aussi sur le en combien de temps on
peut faire évoluer une forêt ma question
pardon on pose parfois des questions de
decia mais on est là pour ça aussi c'est
à dire que voilà forcément ça va prendre
beaucoup beaucoup de temps ça dépend des
essences il y a des essences à
croissance rapide et des essences à
croissante et voyez bien que selon les
essences c'est deux trois dizaines
d'années ou 5 6 dizaines d'années je
veux dire le renouvellement de toutes
les plantes pérennes qu'il s'agisse des
forêts ou de l'arboriculture c'est un
renouvellement lent donc effectivement
il faut prévoir il faut beaucoup
anticiper les plantations forestières et
la sylviculture pour l'adaptation
changement climatique alors je vous
propose maintenant qu'on parle un peu de
votre ministre le ministre de
l'Agriculture il y a il était ici il
suivait la première ministre Elisabeth
borne un peu plus tôt dans l'après-midi
mais alors c'était sur le pavillon
France le pavillon de la pêche française
Matthieu vous vous êtes penché sur les
défis politiques qu'il attendent oui les
défis de Marc fenault alors je donne son
nom parce que c'est un ministre très
discret peu connu du grand public alors
qui c'est pourtant lancé en politique il
y a plus de 3 décennies sous les
couleurs de l'UDF d'abord puis du MoDem
il est né à Paris Marc féno mais il
s'est implanté assez tôt dans dans le
Loir-et-Cher à peu près 25 ans notamment
un marche noir une petite commune de 679
habitants selon le dernier recensement
c'est en pleine bosse c'est donc et on
peut dire qu'il est familier de la
ruralité et puis les familiers du monde
agricole en tout cas de de son côté
institutionnel puisqu'il a passé une
partie de sa carrière dans une chambre
d'agriculture c'est donc plutôt un
profil de de connaisseur même si ce
titulaire d'un dock de sciences de la
vie et de la nature a fini par se
résoudre quand même à faire Sciences Po
ça peut toujours servir en politique on
sait jamais on sait jamais on imagine
que c'est une nomination qui plutôt bien
auprès du monde paysan sur le papier oui
plutôt ça devait bien passer d'abord
parce que il y a pas beaucoup de relais
de la ruralité quand même sur la scène
politique nationale faut rappeler qu'il
y a de moins en moins de paysans qui
font de la politique un niveau national
je parle pas au niveau local parce qu'on
sait qu'il y a beaucoup de mer notamment
dans les petites communes je vous donne
un exemple il y a 18 sénateurs par
exemple qui sont agriculteurs et 12
députés seulement on était à 30 % de
l'Assemblée dans il y a dans les années
50 donc c'était beaucoup plus ensuite
sur le papier je disais le profil de de
Marc fenouil il devait bien passer parce
que c'est pas franchement un homme à
cédé au mode du moment ni aux sirènes
d'alarme écologistes c'est plutôt un
chasseur confirmé tir au fusil il chasse
à l'arc il aime croiser le fer avec avec
les Verts il l'a encore fait hier tiens
sur RTL en prenant de haut la patronne
du parti écolo sur le sujet des méga
bassines notamment celle de sainte
Soline que propose marine tondeuillier à
DEL ministre de faire une agriculture
sans eau elle sait que 95% d'une tomate
c'est de l'eau elle sait que les animaux
ont besoin d'eau pour faire de l'herbe
il faut de l'eau elle propose quoi qu'on
vous a plu bref il s'est moqué d'elle il
l'a prise de haut c'est une pique qui a
été d'autant plus remarquer que jusqu'à
présent je le disais tout à l'heure il
s'est monté très discret Marc Hainaut
trop discret même selon ses amis de la
majorité qui se demandent même ce qu'il
fait alors justement on détaille
maintenant les défis qu'il attendent ben
ils sont nombreux et ils sont lourds
parce qu'on en parle sur ce plateau il
faut tenter de résoudre à la fois toutes
les urgences que traversent le monde
paysan la crise est revenue la crise
évocations la transition écologique la
modernisation la remise en cause ou non
du modèle de production la résistance à
la concurrence mondiale sans oublier
bien sûr l'enjeu de la souveraineté
alimentaire tiens c'est une expression
qui figure désormais au fronton du
ministère d'agriculture c'était pas le
cas avant et donc on en parlera tout à
l'heure et c'est les chantiers majeurs
qui nécessitent une action rapide en
tout cas anticiper pour les pour les
années à venir et le il va devoir
appliquer une feuille de route que
Emmanuel Macron lui a donné c'est ça oui
pour y parvenir Marcelot va devoir
appliquer la feuille de route que lui
est fixé le président de la République
et notamment la préparation d'impact et
d'une loi d'orientation agricole alors
ça c'est très attendu après un round de
débat entamé en région alors c'est une
nouvelle approche c'est très macronien
on va dire pour un ministère qui était
surtout habitué à négocier avec les
syndicats et notamment le le syndicat
majoritaire est-ce que c'est une
solution pour concevoir ou est-ce que
c'est un nouveau machin pour décevoir et
ben c'est toute la question Henri
beespéré ce rende de débat là entamé en
région cette loi d'orientation agricole
qu'est-ce que vous en attendez
pour que ce soit pas un machin pour
décevoir en tout cas je crois que ce que
vous venez de dire c'est que c'est
vraiment un débat de société et que les
consommateurs de plus en plus disent
vous les agriculteurs vous allez pas
faire l'avenir que entre vous entre
organisation agricole comme vous le
citiez très bien il y avait tant une loi
d'orientation c'était les organisations
professionnelles agricoles et le
ministre on se réunissait pendant deux
mois trois mois ce qu'il fallait et
ensemble dans les porter une loi c'était
la cogestion aujourd'hui il y a de plus
en plus des consommateurs les
associations environnementales qui
disent attendez nous on a notre mot à
dire en tant que consommateur et on veut
le dire
vous l'acceptez facilement
c'est difficile de d'avoir vécu au
moment où on disait c'est quand même une
autre affaire à nous agriculteur de
passer notre avenir et le fait de dire
ben écoutez bon on peut toujours écouter
alors on veut écouter déjà objectif pas
déjà effectivement qui disent il faut
Yaka sans eau sans pesticide sans et on
va faire petite agriculture va te dire
que non on regarde les marchés on
regarde où sont les vous citiez dans
votre introduction 65 millions de
consommateurs français pour nous
l'horizon c'est 450 millions de
consommateurs européens en France on est
un pays qui a capacité de nourrir
beaucoup plus que la France et donc on
veut poser ce contexte là avec
effectivement toutes les parties
prenantes d'où cette concertation très
large des groupes de travail à 100
personnes ça on n'y croit pas beaucoup
par contre l'aspect régional les
solutions vont venir dans les régions le
climat ça a été dit aussi sur la forêt
c'est ça il va pas changer de la même
manière dans le sud-est dans le
Sud-Ouest où je suis dans le nord de la
France donc la concertation dans les
régions oui c'est une bonne chose et on
en attend pour répondre à votre question
on entend vraiment de redonner un cap
l'attractivité du métier c'est de
redonner une des perspectives et de la
fierté aux agriculteurs si on leur redit
votre métier c'est la nourriture les les
énergies renouvelables et demain
également l'attractivité de notre
territoire ça redonne les perspectives
de la fiertéométrie agriculteur et les
jeunes viendront naturellement dans
notre métier si on vouloir dire c'est
surproduction pollution etc qui va
s'intéresser à ce métier là donc il y a
un lien étroit et on compte bien on
parle du projet de loi mais il y a aussi
un pacte à même temps et on compte bien
sur ce pacte pour redonner un élan
on repart pour les 20 ans qui viennent
avec de nouvelles perspectives François
purec c'est intéressant cette espèce de
de
cogestion
il faut s'habituer quoi ah ben pas
s'habituer on est déjà dans une approche
très congestionnaire des questions
agricoles c'est pas à nouveau c'est par
contre on a la nécessité de repenser le
pacte qui a été scellé à un moment donné
entre la société française et ces
agriculteurs même si j'aime pas
user cette expression ces agriculteurs
parce que ils appartiennent à personne
ces agriculteurs mais il y a des enjeux
forts à repenser non seulement la
formation mais aussi les compétences et
je trouve que et bien c'est un bon moyen
c'est un bon moment pour faire les
choses on voit bien que le défi
démographique est à relever ce défi il
est il est majeur et je trouve que cette
loi elle offre aussi des perspectives
nouvelles autour de la nécessité de
rebattre les cartes en matière
d'attractivité de formation au métier je
voudrais qu'on parle de cette décision
européenne là aussi on est en pleine
actualité on a beaucoup parlé de de
sécheresse mais c'est décisions de la
Cour de justice européenne concernant
les
néonicotinoïdes donc c'est le 23 janvier
dernier le gouvernement français sous
enfin à la suite de cette décision de la
Cour de justice doit renoncer à
autoriser ces insecticides pour la
culture de la betterave sucrière c'était
une dérogation ce qui est en jeu c'est
une maladie de des betteraves qui
s'appelle la jaunisse qui est propagée
par des pucerons Henri espéré je reviens
vers vous est-ce que ça à quoi comme
conséquence si on est très concret là
pour des producteurs de betteraves
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que ça change
les conséquences c'est qu'il faut mettre
en terre des semences qui auparavant
étaient enrobées d'un insecticide qui
permettait à la plante de se protéger
s'il y avait ces attaques de pucerons
on va pas rentrer à la polémique mais
bon par contre les pays voisins qui vont
appliquer la même décision de justice
eux ont gardé la possibilité d'y aller
avec des produits en pulvérisation ce
que la France s'était interdit il y a 4
5 ans en disant non pulvérise plus on va
juste enrober la graine comme ça ça
partira pas l'atmosphère on vous dites
pays voisins c'est les pays voisins
d'Europe là le Magne par exemple à
garder la possibilité de pulvériser des
produits insecticides ce que nous on
n'aura plus la conséquence très concrète
c'est que si au printemps il y a attaque
depuis ce rond ce qui dépendra du climat
afin de plusieurs facteurs et que la
jaunisse se développe dès que par
endroits les betteraves vont mourir et
que les usines manqueront de betteraves
et feront moins de sucre et qu'on ira
acheter du sucre pro
issu de la déforestation au Brésil et
issu de la canne à sucre et là on est
dans notre second débat qu'on va aborder
dans quelques minutes sur la
souveraineté alimentaire on tout ça ce
ce boucle évidemment donc vous dites
quoi vous dites qu'on est alors c'est
une décision de justice européenne on
n'a pas d'autre choix que de que de
l'appliquer mais ça veut dire quoi on a
été mieux 10 ans à une époque c'est ça
tout à fait on a pensé à une époque que
depuis le vériser c'était plus l'avenir
donc on a écrit dans une loi
interdiction de pulvériser mais on
savait qu'on avait la solution de
rechange d'enrobé la semence avec juste
quelques milligrammes de de produits qui
étaient enterrés donc qui était pas
aérienne ni rien aujourd'hui on nous
retire ce que nous on s'était gardé
comme seul solution on en a plus aucune
et on nous l'a fait trop vite parce
qu'on sait que on a déjà entamé des
recherches qui vont faire que demain on
aura peut-être des variétés de
betteraves qui seront naturellement
tolérante assez mal à dilat on aura
probablement des produits biosourcés qui
permettront aussi de lutter et ça ça
mettra trois quatre ans à venir on a mis
beaucoup d'argent sur y compris la
filière bettera hier y compris les
agriculteurs et mais ça met un peu de
temps arriver donc on trouve que ça va
trop vite Marion Guillot on peut aussi
dire que malheureusement cette solution
technologique ça fait trop longtemps
qu'on l'attend quoi oui ces questions
sont extrêmement difficiles parce que
les noces
néonicotinoïdes ça fait au moins 20 ans
qui sont mis en cause qu'on a commencé à
avoir des effets sur les abeilles je
veux dire les signaux avant-coureurs
datent ça fait longtemps qu'on sait
qu'il y a un problème potentiel donc la
vraie difficulté c'est de savoir à
partir de quand les professionnels les
sociétés de Phyto les tout tout
l'appareil agricole cherche des
alternatives et on a toujours tendance à
attendre le jour de l'interdiction
absolue pour commencer les travaux
sérieux de recherche donc tout ça c'est
vraiment une question et peut-être que
ça doit faire partie d'impact c'est une
question d'anticipation collective
c'est-à-dire on se dit ce produit là on
a identifié ces dangers
on voit que il faut s'en priver à
perspective de 5 ans de 10 ans et
qu'est-ce qu'on met en route dès
maintenant pour avoir des alternatives
on a vraiment trop tendance à voir
arriver à attendre que l'obstacle soit
présent pour dégager les alternatives
c'est donc c'est toujours un compromis
entre une décision qui est sentie comme
prématuré et le fait que si la décision
est pas prise les travaux se font pas
d'une manière générale sur on va dire la
question de l'utilisation de produits
chimiques d'un tranchant je vous propose
un autre témoignage dans ce dans ce
débat celui d'un céréalier en
Eure-et-Loir voilà ce qu'il dit sur il
dit un peu faites-nous confiance c'est
un ras-le-bol général de toute la
suradministration la surglementation
qu'on subit en agricole alors oui il y a
des interdictions mais
c'est délicat de se battre pour défendre
des molécules alors que derrière on a
toute une ambiance qui est contre en
fait on défend plutôt le savoir-faire
qui peut être amené à utiliser ces
molécules François Purcell je me tourne
vers nous parce que je trouve ça
intéressant ce qui dit c'est compliqué
de défendre des molécules vous voyez
déjà dans les termes qu'il emploie bon
il fait il fait un peu attention parce
qu'il y a un climat général
effectivement il y a et et de toute
façon on n'a pas d'autre choix que de
trouver des solutions pour pour réduire
les effets du réchauffement climatique
quand on est il dit faites-nous
confiance il y a un savoir-faire dans
l'utilisation de ces molécules est-ce
qu'on peut entendre cet argument
c'est-à-dire qu'on a l'impression que
d'un côté c'est il faut tout bannir et
de l'autre c'est on n'a pas d'autre
choix d'utiliser des des produits
chimiques donc il y a forcément une voie
médiane oui la plupart des agriculteurs
sont dans cette voie médiane alors l'une
des forces aussi de la profession
agricole c'est d'être bien doté
d'institutions d'organisation je pense
aux instituts techniques il y a
l'appareil de recherche fondamentale et
appliquées qui est là également pour
accompagner les agriculteurs pour
trouver justement ces voies médianes il
y a un enjeu en matière de développement
d'accompagnement il est important
justement de doter d'outils on en
parlait tout à l'heure en matière de
conseils pour faire en sorte justement
d'atteindre cette voix cette voix
médiane mais on parlait de modèle tout à
l'heure et de d'anciens modèles une
modèle bah non il y en a plusieurs alors
il y en a peut-être plusieurs celui qui
a dominé pendant des décennies c'était
un modèle qui utilisait beaucoup de
produits chimiques on va pas dire le
contraire oui tout à fait tout à fait
mais alors il y a deux choses il y a les
modèles socio-techniques conventionnel
versus bio etc et puis il y a les
modèles d'organisation du travail
l'exploitation familiale de taille
moyenne petite ou grande bon il y a une
confusion souvent qui s'opère entre la
petite et cette exploitation qui serait
finalement que bio ouverture on a des
défis à relever aujourd'hui pour
accompagner cette diversité de structure
d'exploitation alors peut-on parler de
modèle en ce sens que finalement les
stratégies elles sont multiples
aujourd'hui en agriculture elles sont à
la fois commerciale artisanales
patrimoniales industriel on a oui des
outils qui ont été utilisés à un moment
donné qui va falloir peut-être laisser
de côté mais si tenté qu'il y ait des
solutions et c'est là que les
institutions les organisations comme
l'appareil de recherche ou les instituts
techniques bien peuvent contribuer à ces
évolutions on parle souvent de on en
parle encore d'ailleurs d'agriculture
intensive c'est de ce modèle-là moi dont
je parle qui a été le modèle dominant de
depuis des décennies alors il y a eu il
y a eu un modèle qui a permis quand même
à notre pays de passer de moments où on
n'arrivait pas à nourrir les quelques
caractères de Français qui étaient pas
encore reçoit de ces millions à un pays
qui nourrit largement les soins de 5
millions qui est devenu exportateur qui
a développé des territoires des
entreprises ont créé des emplois c'est
quand même de ce modèle là dont on parle
mais à quel jour à quel prix
environnemental vous voyez ce que je
veux dire et je dis pas que toute la
société française
a oublié de se poser la question pendant
des décennies il y a 10 ans qui disaient
ça donc petit à on a constaté avec des
études avec des des prélèvements fins
qui avaient des résidus de pesticides
que dans l'eau on retrouvait
certainement matière donc petit à petit
chaque fois qu'on l'a découvert on n'a
pas dit tant pis on continue à chaque
fois on adapté les pratiques les
nitrates dans l'eau aujourd'hui on en
parle pratiquement plus parce que dans
toutes les autres c'est en train de
s'améliorer mais il faut du temps pour
que ça s'améliore parce que les
pratiques d'agriculteurs ont évolué donc
on est dans une profession qui fait
évoluer en permanence son métier donc il
faut pas critiquer le modèle ancien le
productivisme c'est pas un gros mot
si on ne garde pas l'oeil sur la
productivité de nos hectares demain en
importera encore plus alimentation pour
nourrir nos propres concitoyens donc
c'est pas un gros mot par contre ceux
qui font regarder c'est l'utilisation
qu'effectivement de certains nombre de
matières comme ça a été dit c'est pas un
gros mot pour nous le coup c'est qu'on
dit là c'est probablement qu'on a pas
assez de robes ce qu'on critique c'est
quand on dit aux Français vous arrêtez
l'année prochaine d'utiliser tel produit
alors qu'autour de nous les Espagnols
les Italiens les Allemands continuent de
l'utiliser chaque enfant qui a une
décision européenne on sait on a fait en
sorte de la compagnie et après Marion
Guillou le disait agissent le titre bien
évidemment que s'il y a 5 ans 10 ans la
recherche avait commencé à chercher des
solutions en se disant ça sera le
problème des 10 prochaines années
peut-être qu'aujourd'hui on en aura peu
plus il n'est jamais trop tard oui nous
on l'a mis tous les instituts au travail
les bons de commande qu'on a passé c'est
trop bon des alternatives et chaque fois
qu'on aura les alternatives c'est le
contrat de solutions qu'a porté la FNSEA
à bout de bras chaque fois qu'il y a une
alternative on alternative et on arrête
la solution chimique Marion Guillou
est-ce qu'il y a effectivement des
distorsions de concurrence au sein même
de l'Europe ce qui peut sembler quand
même absurde alors oui il arrive qui est
ne serait-ce que ces dérogations sur les
néonicotinoïdes il y avait un principe
d'interdiction et un certain nombre de
pays avaient accordé des dérogations
dont la France d'ailleurs et à ce
moment-là la Cour de justice se met à
dire c'est maintenant ça y est c'est
fini il y a plus de dérogation la cause
est trop voilà et devrait être entendu
et on fait plus donc oui il y a des
décalages dans le temps oui il y a des
molécules des principes actifs qui sont
autorisés au niveau de Bruxelles vous
savez que les préparations se sont
encore des autorisations nationales donc
la manière dont on applique la molécule
active ce sont des décisions nationales
donc vous avez raison il peut y avoir
des différences entre les pays européens
mais je dirais encore plus encore plus
des des problèmes de concurrence avec
les modèles de production or Europe et
il faut être extrêmement attentif parce
que c'est notamment un des sujets sur le
climat ou de fait dans nos pays on va
faire en sorte d'atténuer le changement
climatique on va essayer de stocker plus
de carbone enfin il faut mettre en route
tout un système à la fois mieux adapté
au changement climatique et qui
contribue moins aux émissions de gaz à
effet de serre mais voyez bien que si on
fait ça tout seul dans notre coin et que
les d'autres pays continuent comme avant
ça marche pas d'où l'importance et c'est
un peu le sens de ces décisions
compliquées à mettre en place mais
l'importance de ces décisions
européennes sur le fait de d'avoir une
des mécanismes d'entrée et puis chaque
fois que c'est possible qu'un désaccords
commerciaux d'avoir des mécanismes de
réciprocité sinon c'est extrêmement
difficile de continuer comme avant je
voudrais qu'on termine ce premier débat
sur la question de la rémunération des
agriculteurs en écoutant un extrait de
la visite de du prénom République samedi
ici
au Salon International de l'Agriculture
ils mettaient la pression sur les
distributeurs écoutez
faut que sur certains biens les
distributeurs puissent aider quand il
n'y a pas d'impact sur les producteurs
on peut pas dire d'un seul coup
l'aliment pas dire le tout et son
contraire donc notre alimentation doit
en préserver la valeur pour que nos
producteurs notent nos agriculteurs
puissent vivre de ce revenu ensuite il
faut que avec nos distributeurs on fasse
très attention parce qu'il y a certaines
marques qui sont pas celles produites
par nos agriculteurs sont souvent des
marques de distributeur qui ont une
envolée des prix qui touche le
portefeuille de notre consommateurs donc
faut faire cet effort faut être très
vigilant mais là on a besoin d'un effort
collectif d'un engagement c'est ça ce
que je demande aussi à nos distributeurs
aujourd'hui ah oui bien espérer c'est le
moment des négociations là avec la
grande distribution c'est terminé on en
est où de ça c'est terminé théoriquement
par la de par la loi demain soir ok donc
effectivement comme tout comme
d'habitude pendant le Salon de
l'Agriculture mercredi midi on va voir
les téléphones qui vont chauffer pour
savoir quel était le entreprise
agroalimentaire si elle a réussi à
passer effectivement les hausses qui
permettent de rémunérer le producteur
puisque voilà c'est avec le contrat qui
il va signer avec le distributeur qui se
retournera vers le producteur à disant
je peux vous rémunérer où on est obligé
d'aller rogner et donc c'est il y a une
tendance il y a une tendance qui est pas
très agréable puisque les distributeurs
continuent de mettre encore une pression
extraordinaire sur les entreprises
agroalimentaires
et donc forcément à un moment ou un
autre ça se retournera aussi vers le
producteur c'est ce qu'on crée alors
normalement on a la loi egalim qui doit
protéger le coût de production pour le
producteur donc le producteur devrait
être épargné mais encore faudra-t-il
aller vérifier que la loi egalim
s'applique partout c'est la question que
j'avais posé quand même des dispositifs
qui ont été mis en place vous êtes vous
avez dubitatif sur les faits
il y a eu des dispositifs parce que
sinon habituellement au sol de
l'agriculture vous savez ce qu'elle est
arrivée la semaine après de salon c'est
à dire qu'on avait vu les conclusions
des la grade de distribution qui
avait encore
oublié d'augmenter les tarifs de rachat
et donc les entreprises qui revenaient
vers les agriculteurs disent à écouter
désolé on peut pas vous augmenter donc
ça ça plus possible théoriquement
partout il y a des contrats partout ça
pique malheureusement c'est pas partout
le cas mais nous on sera vigilant
qu'effectivement pour que ce soit pas le
producteur surtout dans la période
actuelle de d'inflation des coûts de
production qui paient la facture de ce
que voudra faire le distributeur pour
maintenir ses marges puisque on a quand
même constaté c'était le seul maillot
qui continue d'avoir des marges
conséquentes un dernier mot tient
François Purcell peut-être parce que
dans votre livre on voit une agriculture
que nous mais aussi on connaît pas
forcément il y a de plus en plus
agriculteurs qui ont plusieurs métiers
quoi qui ont un autre métier à côté etc
c'est ce qu'on appelle le pluri actif
c'est pas moins de 30% des moins de 40
ans qui s'installe aujourd'hui qui sont
plus réactifs un chiffre dans le seul
département de l'Aisne c'est pas moins
de 50% des jeunes et moins jeunes qui
s'installent qui gardent un pied dans
une activité autre qu'agricole parce que
on entre plus tardivement dans les
métiers de l'agriculture et on en sort
parfois plus précocement merci beaucoup
et c'est à découvrir dans votre livre
une agriculture sans agriculteur qui est
publié aux éditions des Presses de
Sciences Po Bercy à tous d'avoir
participé à ce premier